خالد يوسف مخرج سينمائي كبير غايب عن
الاخراج لسنوات وفي هذا الرمضان بسجل عوده
قويه للمشهد الفني ولكن من باب الدراما
ففي اول اعماله الدراميه بيقدم المخرج
خالد يوسف مسلسل سر الباتر اللي هو من
تاليفه اخراجه وقصه الراحل يوسف ادريس هذا
المسلسل الضخم انتاجيا واللي بيجمع اكثر
من 60 نجم ونجمه والاف الممثلين هو مستوحى
من قصه للاديب الكبيره الراحل يوسف ادريس
وبدور احداثه في مرحله زمنيتين حول
السلطان حامد وهو بطل شعبي وقت الحمله
الفرنسيه بيتحول الاسطوره لها اضرحه
ومقامات في العديد من قرى مصر وفي بياع
مجوهرات بيلاقي نفسه بيحاول يكشف سر
السلطان واللي متابع المسلسل مثلنا اكيد
جالس متحمس علشان يعرف
السر لما الغزال هجموا على مصر
امنوا السلطان حامد وقال لهم
والله ما تدخلوا الا على جثتي
انا حامد يا نابليون
انا مش بدور على كنز انا بدور على حكايه
السلطان
احنا اتولدنا المهام موجود في البلد الناس
اللي بيحفروا في المقام دول بيدوروا عليه
مدفون الورقه دي شكلها من ايام الحمله
الفرنسيه
العمل الضخم جدا انتاجيا مثل ما قلنا ومن
الاعمال اللي حاصدها النسب مشاهده عاليه
وعليها تعليقات وكلام كثير
ومعنا من القاهره المخرج الكبير خالد يوسف
اهلا فيك معنا خالد كل عام وانت بالف خير
كل سنه وانتم طيبين
وبارك لك على العوده الكبيره صراحه هو
صادم انك انت هذا اول مسلسل لك
صادم ليه
الموضوع لان كلنا متعودين انه عندك تاريخ
طويل وكذا وكذا وكذا يعني الواحد لما
بيرجع بطالع بيقول اه هو ما عمل ولا مسلسل
قبل كده
انا ما عملتش بس انا لما قدمت المسلسل ده
قدمت اكني بعمل فيلم سينما ما عملتش على
نسق الدراما التلفزيونيه اللي متعودين
عليها يعني
لا ما تغيرش حاجه انا بقول لك انا عملت
المسلسل اكني بعمل فيلم سينما
بنفس التكنيك بنفس
الاتقان بتاع
اللي بحتاجه عشان اعمل شوت سينما هو نفس
الوقت اللي خدته في صنع كل شط في هذا
المسلسل ما اعتبرتوش مسلسل
اعتبرته فيلم سينمائي طويل هو
في كتير على السوشيال ميديا بياخدوا لقطات
من المسلسل وبيحطوا فيها وبيشرحوا فيها
انه اخراجيا انت كيف عامل الموضوع بالفعل
كانه فيلم يعني بس ايش اللي لفتك تحديدا
في هذه الروايه وحسسك انه لا مسلسل مو
فيلم
يعني اما قريت الروايه زمان يعني انا
مشتري الروايه دي عشان اعملها من سنه 2009
يعني حلم قديم ليا من الافلام او من
الاعمال اللي انا كان نفسي اعملها من زمان
كان لان الروايه يعني بديعه
يوسف ادريس كاتب فيها فكره تقعدي تتعمقي
فيها تلاقي فيها
تطلعي منها 100 فكره او 100 خط درامي يعني
فلقيتها لقيتها كبيره تحتمل انها تبقى 30
حلقه من غير ما نعمل لمط ولا تطويل انت
عارفه احيانا الدرامز التلفزيونيه بتبقى
فيها فن مط وتطويل اللحظه لكن
انا عامل فن تكثيف في اللحظه زي ما بعمل
في السينما بالظبط
والدراما اكبر من النهضه يعني ممكن تتعمل
في 60 حلقه 30 حلقه هم يعني ومكسب جدا
الخطوط الدراميه يعني صحيح ايوه هو في
كثير خط الدراميه في القصه الان بعد ما
عملت هذه التجربه هل ممكن نقول انه
حتكررها هل حنرجع نشوف خالد يوسف خلاص
مثلا نجم النجوم رمضان دائما
العمليه مرهقه جدا جدا لانه انت بتعملي زي
ما قلت لك لما
لما نويت اعمل العمل عملته على النسق
سينمائي وعملته اكني بعمل فيلم فارهقني
جدا لان ان حلقه يعني بتتكلمي في 16 ساعه
ونص 16 ساعه ونص دول يعملوا لي خمس افلام
يعني اعمل خمس افلام احسن يعني طيب فخلص
يعني نقدر نقول هذه التجربه حتكون الوحيده
اليتيمه يعني
تقريبا انا مش ناوي اعمل ضربه تلفزيونيه
ثاني يعني انا عملت ده اطلاله مني على في
البيوت كاريير تاني خالص غير السينما
وتمت اسهامي في الدراما التليفزيونيه لما
تتعمل من وجهه نظري تتعمل ازاي فعملتها
ولسه بقيه الاحداث يعني او بقيه الحلقات
وكده اكتفيت يعني انا كده مبسوط وصلت اللي
عندك حاسس انه فيها طيب الان يمكن واحده
من الاشياء اللي بيتكلموا عنها الناس او
بيتكلم عنها حتى المسلسل الحديث عن الهويه
المصريه الحديثه عن انه العلاقه بين مثلا
المسلم والقبطي وحتى الهويه المصريه من
منظور الفرنسيين او المستشرق وهو مثلا
بيكتب عن مصر والهويه المصريه والشخصيه
المصريه وما الى ذلك ليش حسيت انك مهم انك
تقدم شيء يحط الهويه المصريه في نقاط او
يوضحها
اولا هي الروايه قايمه على ده يعني
قائمه على فكره ان ليه الاستعمار الفرنسي
هو الاستعمار الوحيد اللي قاعد في مصر
ثلاث سنين فقط
لكل الاستعمار احنا عندنا 7000 سنه عمر
تاريخ مصر يعني
الاستعمار اولا استعمرنا تقريبا معظم
فترات حياتنا يعني 7000 سنه تقريبا احنا
مستعمرين يعني فترات طويله جدا ما فيش قوه
عظمى الا ما جات احتلتنا يعني وكانوا
بيقعدوا كتير قوي يعني اما تيجي تفكري من
اول الهكسوس اللي قعدوا 108 سنه مرورا بقى
بالبطالمه بالعثمانيين بالمماليك كل ده
مئات السنين قعدوا الفرنساويين قعدوا فقط
ثلاث سنين وهنا السؤال ليه دول بالذات
سنين فقط لان دول اقتربوا بالهويه الوطنيه
اقتربوا من محاوله تغيير ملامح الشخصيه
المصريه كل الاستعمار اللي جاء كان مستبد
كان فاشي كان ناهب لصلوات البلد كان كل
الاوصاف اللي ممكن تقوليها في الاستعمار
موجوده لكن ما حدش اقترب من ثقافه
المصريين ولا من محاوله تغيير ملامحهم ولا
محاوله تغيير عاداتهم ولا محاوله اضافه
منظومه قيم مختلفه مغيره المجتمع المصري
غير الفرنساويين عشان كده رفزوا سريعا جدا
المصريين هنا بيحصل بقى قرون الاستشعار
بتطلع
بتتحفز
وعملوا حتى بالعقل الجمعي مش ضروري يكونوا
واعيين ومحللين الكلام اللي انا بقوله ده
بس بالله وعي بتاعهم بيستنفروا فورا لما
حد بيقترب من هويتهم او ملامح شخصيتهم او
طريقه حياتهم او ثقافتهم بشكلها
فهنا الفكره اللي احنا بنقدمها في الروايه
في المسلسل ده انه
المصريين حاسين تجاه الهويه الوطنيه
بتاعتهم واتجاه ملامحهم
وده هيبقى له يعني كلام معاصر يعني انا
ليه جايب معاصر وليه جايب تاريخي لان احنا
عندنا تجربه اخرى في العصر الحديث اللي هي
الاحتلال الاخواني لمصر لم يستمر اكثر من
سنه هو الاخر لانه برضو اقترب من الهويه
الوطنيه واقترب من محاوله تحت تغيير ملامح
الشخصيه المصريه برضو المصريين استنفروا
وطردوه في سنه
فالمقاربه ما بين الاحتلالين دول هي اللي
استوقفتني وعشان كده انا عملت العصرين
يعني الروايه بتاعت يوسف ابليس ما فيهاش
عصرين فيها عصر واحد والتاريخ
فانا بشوف انه اولا التاكيد على الهويه
الوطنيه والتاكيد على فكره الانتماء
للدوله الوطنيه المصريه الجامعه يعني دي
مساله شديده الاهميه في كل زمان ومكان
يعني مش بس في لحظات التحدي ولا في فقط
ولكن ده مفروض طول الوقت ناكد عليه يعني
خالد يعني انه في بعض المشاهد اللي دار
فيها هذا الموضوع او تم ذكر هذا الموضوع
انه كان في مباشره او اسلوب مباشر او انت
متعمد هذا الشيء يمكن ما ادري يعني مثلا
لما تم الحديث عن مثلا انه القبطي والمسلم
والتاكيد انه نحن اخوان وانت معايا وانا
معاك والكلام هذا كله كان واضحه الرساله
مباشره
ممكن تعتبريها مباشره بس هي كانت مهمه
للفرشه الاساسيه عشان ضمن الاحداث اللي
جايه وضمن كل التطور الدرامي اللي جاي
الحاجات دي في الاحداث من غير ما نتكلم
عنها فكان يمكن هي الفرشه ديت الاساسيه
خاصه انه كان مطروح السؤال انه هل نحارب
الفرنسيين عشان هم احتلال كافر
احتلال يعني بنعتبره كافر ويبقى ويبقى
اكثر ضررا من احتلال المماليك ولا لا
هنا كان مهم ان احنا نوصل انه ما تفرقش
احتلال شكله ايه
والناس اللي بتخلط ما بين
ما بين
المسيحي الفرنسي مثلا والمسيح المصري لا
المسيح المصري هو المسلم المصري يعني دي
برضه قضيه اشكاليه موجوده على الارض طول
عمرها بالتاكيد عليها يعني فكره ان في حد
يقول لك ان المسلم الاندونيسي اقرب لي
مثلا من المسيح المصري انا ضد الكلام ده
انا المصري هو المصري ايا كان ديانتو فانت
اكيد عليها كان بعتقد ان مهم وجبت احتياط
الدرامي اللي هم كانوا بيتناقشوا في نروح
نحارب الفرنساويين ولا لا يعني
لازم نحاربهم بس خليني كمان خالد يمكن
عشان انقلك لنقطه الثانيه صار جدل على
موضوع الموسيقى صاروا بيقولوا انه خالد
يوسف بيستعمل مقطوعات موسيقيه سبق
واستعملها في افلامه لاي درجه هذا الكلام
صحيح
كلام صحيح جدا بس يعني الناس دي بتنسى بس
انا عملت فيلم اسمه حين ميسر تمام هذا
الفيلم ما استخدمت ما عملتلوش مزيكا ما
عملتلوش ما جبتش موسيقارى عشان يعلف له
مزيكا انا خدت مزيكا افلامي السابقه كان
فيلم خدت مزيكه فيلم العاصفه
للاستاذ كمال الطويل وخدت مزيكا ياسر عبد
الرحمن في خيانه مشروعه وعملت بيهم مزيكا
فيلم حين ميزره بالكامل بالكامل وكتبت على
موسيقى كمان الطويل وكان توفى حتى وخدت
طبعا الاذن من من ولاده يعني ان انا
استخدم المزيكا
واستخدمتها هي ومزيكا ياسر عبد الرحمن انا
رايي انه
المشكله المزيكا وجدان اي عمل فني بالنسبه
لشغلنا يعني فانا لما بحط تما موسيقيه
وبتعلق بها وما بعرفش اشوف المشهد من
غيرها ما بقدرش اشيلها يعني ساعات بحط
مزيكا جيد عقبال ما نعمل المزيكا وبعدين
بعد ما اجي احط المزيكا اللي اتعملت مخصوص
ما احسش المشهد زي ما كنت حاسه لما كنت
حاطط المزيكا الجيد فبقول لا خلاص هسيب هي
مزيكه قفلاني وانا مستاذن اصحابها فايه
المشكله مش فاهم انت ليه في النهايه تقول
والله المزيكا مش معبره لك والله تقول
والله انا ما عجبتنيش خالص ما عجبنيش
المشهد حقك المطلق وانا حقي المطلق ان انا
استخدم المزيكا اللي انا عايزها يعني ما
تقوليش انت هتستخدمش ايه يعني انت كمشاهد
وناقض من حقك تقول ان المزيكا غير معبره
غير محيه لم تضيف بعدا يعني كل ده من حقك
لكن مش من حقك تقول لي استخدم دي ولا ما
تستخدمهاش طيب اسمح لي يعني خالد خليني بس
كمان اخذ بعض التعليقات الناس واسالك عنها
يعني احنا رغم كل الحفاوه طبعا والاشادات
اللي صايره حوالين المسلسل حابه انه نكسب
انك معانا علشان نستعرض معاك كم تعليق من
التعليقات الناس اللي من ايام تم تداول
صور مثلا مشاهد من مسلسل سمعها البعض
اخطاء تاريخيه بعضهم سموها اخطاء اخراجيه
يعني فمثلا ظهور احد الممثلين بحذاء رياضي
لاحدى الماركات العالميه اللي ما كانت
موجوده في هذاك الوقت في كمان سوره الفنان
ايمن اشتيوي بيقوم بشخصيه نابليون وانه
طويل القامه ونابليون عرف عنه قصر القان
ما غير الصور اللي تداولت عن لبس وملامح
الجنود الفرنسيين
خليني يعني ابتدي معك بهذه النقاط يعني
اللي الناس تتحدثوا عنها مثلا مشهد حاجات
كتير منها الحاجات اللي حضرتك قلتيها
وغيرها وانا هرد يعني
اللي بيتكلموا على
معلش قولي لي التلات نقاط مثلا قصه الحذاء
قصه الحذاء انا عندي الف كومبارس
تمام او الفين كومبارس في اليوم الكنترول
عليه يعني فكره ان انا وبحرك المجاميع دي
في معركه
الشركه عليهم من المساعدين برده يعني ما
هو ما كانش 100%
فحصل لما حصلت هذه الغلطه انا اكتشفتها في
التصوير مش في مش بعد ما اتعرض
وعملت اخر شيلت الولد الكومبارس اللي كان
لابس ده وجبنا ولد ثاني كان لابس الجزمه
التاريخيه هو ثاني كسر ان هو يلبس الجزمه
يعني
وقعدت الشوط وحطيت الشورت الحقيقي وحصل
غلطه في تركيب المسلسل انه حط الشرطه ده
بدل ده تايم كود غلط محطوط واول ما اتعرض
المسلسل فورا في اول بعد اول عرض شفت
البتاع قلت لهم يا جماعه الشوط اتحط غلط
بدلت وخلاص يعني يعني خطا وسهل صحيح بعتذر
عنه لكن ما هواش بقى هو ده انا
جايب ضارب بعرض الحائط وبلبس الناس كوتشي
وماركه يعني مش معقوله يعني لازم كل هذا
الجهد وعامل كل هذه الملابس التاريخيه
المنضبطه وحركه المجاميع دي كلها والاف
المجاميع وهاجي على حذاء لواحد من
الكومبارسات وهعمل فيه يعني كمان علقوا
على الملابس قالوا انه بعض الملابس وانه
تاريخيا وما تاريخيا والاشياء هذه
والاشكال الاشكال اشكال الجنود
يعني اللي اتكلموا على الملابس
القطن القطن المصري من القطن المصري ما
كانش موجود ده محمد علي اللي جابه من
الهند دي بقى فزلكه من طراز رفيع يعني لان
القطن المصري
اللي جابه محمد علي من الهند اللي هو
القطن طويل التيل لكن القطن المصري موجود
من 7000 سنه والملابس القطنيه موجوده ثم
بقى افترضي ان ما عندناش قطن مصري انا
عايز اعرف مين بقى الجميل العظيم اللي قدر
بقى يخش جوه الشاشه ويمسك القماش كده
ويقول لا والله ده مش كتان ده قطن ده ازاي
يعني يعني
فكره ان انت تلبسي اعداد المجاميع دي كلها
ملابس
بتزعجك لما انت عامل عمل بهذه الضخامه
ويجي احد يعلق
نيش خالص ده بتعمل
واهتمام وده ساعدني وما فيش عندي مشكله
خالص بس يعني
في محاولات
اما تيجي بقى تتكلمي على نابليون يعني
برده يعني
الناس اللي بتتكلم كده يعني ما تعرفش يعني
ايه فن اصلا يعني لما جه يوسف شاهين عمل
فيلم عمل فيلم نصر صلاح الدين الناصر صلاح
الدين ده كان وصفه تاريخيا عريض المنكبين
طويل ما اعرفش ايه الى اخر الكلام ده اوكي
احمد مظهر ده طوله 165 سم
يعني حضرتك اطول منه
هو الحقيقه يعني يا خالد لو انت عرفت طول
الحقيقي ما كنت هتقول الجمله هذه لانه
احمد مظهر اطول مني بكثير الحقيقه يعني
الله يرحمه
احمد مظهر كان قصير جدا كان 165 سم 168 سم
يوسف شاهين جابه وفي دور ناصر صلاح الدين
ما حدش قال له ما اعرفش ايه الرؤيه بتاعه
المخرج في اختيار الدور يعني لو انا بقدم
نابليون انا عايز اقدم نابليون عظيم مثلا
غير لما اكون عايز اقدمه ومستبد غير لما
اكون عايز كل واحد انا عايز اقدم جمال عبد
الناصر ان هو اعظم شخصيه تاريخيه
فبجيب الكاستنج اللي يحقق اللي اللي
يكسبني جوله في في الرؤيه بتاعتي لو عايز
اقول استبداد
فبرضو الكاستنج تلعب على موضوع الشكل
ما بجسدش انا شخص يعني لما عملوا نيكسون
لما عملوا نيكسون جابوا جاك نيكلسون
ما عملوش حتى تاتش مكياج
دول كانوا بهايم دول يعني
ما قالوش علاقه بينكسون خالص واخد بال
حضرتك وجابوك وعملوا زي ما هو لان القضيه
مش قضيه تطابق الشكل القضيه قضيه رؤيه
المخرج في الشخصيه نفسها
فمش قضيه ان انا بتجيب واحد اهو ده كان
واحد معاصر بقى ميكسون كان معاصر نيكسون
معاصر وعايش مش بقى واحد من التاريخ هو يا
دوبك مرسومه له صوره انت انت وراك صوره
صاحيه خالد
هو الوحيد
الصوره الوحيده اللي وراك
لا ورايا عبد المنعم رياض وقدامي جمال عبد
الناصر وقدام يوسف شاهين اهو اوريكي
بن ناصر وده عبد المنعم
طيب يلا حبينا نطمن على الغرفه والصور
فبقول لك يعني في محاوله للفزلكه واللي
يقول لك مثلا ما كانش في عجله تجرها احصنه
في هذا العصر يعني جبت منين هذا المصدر
العجيب يعني اذا كان المصريين يعرفوا
العجله الحربيه من ايام احمص منك من كام
الف سنه يعني اللي يعرفوا حضارتهم العجله
الحربيه اللي بيجرها حصان هيقعدوا الاف
السنين مش هيتفطك ذهنهم ان هم يعملوا عجله
بيجرها حصان للحياه العامه يعني ففي
محاوله للتصيد طول الوقت ومحاوله لانه حد
يبدو ان هو عالم ببواطن الامور اللي يقول
لك القطن المصري معرفش ايه واللي يقول لك
العجله ما كانتش موجوده واللي يقول لك
لانك انت خالد يوسف ولا تصيد عام
هو التصيد بالعموم من السوشيال ميديا
عامله هذا
بشكل عام لكن انا انا انا شخص مثير للجدل
طول الوقت وفي ناس طول الوقت
اعتقد المسلسل ده لو عليه اسم اخر غيري
يمكن ده كله ما كانش حصل وكانوا قال والله
ده فتح جديد في الدراما التليفزيونيه وانه
[ضحك]
على العموم يا خالد الناس بتتابعه وبتتفرج
والمسلسل عامل اصداء مراه كبيره انا شاكره
جدا انك انت اعطيتنا اليوم من وقتك
وطبعا سعه صدرك انك انت لتقبلك كل الاراء
والرد
ولا حتى في الفزلكه يعني ببقى سعيد لها
وانا في النهايه عامل عمل انا سعيد به
وفخور بيه وعملت ما املك يعني والحمد لله
الاخطاء صحيح والاصدقاء باينه كبيره
والاهتمام كبير فعلا
المسلسل ناجح وعلى نسبه مشاهده يعني
خلاص بقى اللي عايز بقى يقول شويه حاجات
كده في النص ويعمل بوست حلو ويتشير ماشي
ما فيش مشكله يعني اوكي بنشكرك على وجودك
معانا كان معنا من القاهره المخرج الكبير
خالد يوسف شكرا لك يا خالد
[موسيقى]